bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti in
questo nuovo video sono la vj e oggi
siamo su don't look back 2
lo sto facendo un videogame horror
ragazzi con bonus riff che sarebbe il
seguito di quello che ho fatto l'ultima
volta e niente ragazzi spero vi piaccia
quindi lo so cazzi nostri perfetto
ragazzi ci siamo già un altro gioco era
esageratamente bello quindi non vedo
l'ora di vedere fantastico complimenti
per l'arredamento bravi qualcuno c'ha
voglia di spiegarmi come ci sono
arrivati che delle rocce l'eroe no no è
no lasciamo perdere le ragnatele lascia
andiamo avanti così con questo posto è
veramente figo e 120 fps la madonna
ragazzi sto come aperto stop che pensavo
fossero ragni non usano anni ok perfetto
se c'era c'era un bambino che correrebbe
certo questo è un parco giochi
siamo finiti a mirabilandia credo non so
neanche dove devo andare buon pomeriggio
scaldi a mano ma è un'ombra pensavo
fosse una bambina una cosa leggera no
invece no che è perfetto ragazzi non ho
ancora capito dove devo andare lì
precisa ancora ragnatele giuro mi
incazzo
cosa perché apparso l'effetto sonoro di
di insidiosa prendendo per il culo se
120 a una chiave perfetto va bene ok
cosa sia aperto braga non mi è piaciuta
sta cosa però perché c'è scritto tre
forse devo trovare le chiavi numerate
allora io possa aprire a porta al numero
2 credo credo che sia così e poi potrei
sbagliarmi comunque c'era un bambino
ecco di qua perfetto prima o poi dovrà
succedere qualcosa
don't look basta sta scritta cos'è ci
sono celle la madonna che gabinetto
signori la prima gara non c'è stata più
un cazzo
oh mio dio va bene va bene allora è
grazie e grazie mille molto gentile da
posso sedermi
no perché l'avevo già adocchiato prima
mi sono già innamorato cioè per caso una
fine a questa cosa brutta cosa diavolo è
quello devo per caso aprire quella porta
questa volta che ti posso possono perché
kick ass è sta roba
vabbè io prendo posso prendere in
contento volevo prendere il coltello non
sta merda mi serviva l'altro però grazie
lo stesso molto gentile o prendere il
coltello no giusto per difendersi no
niente con te loro lasciamoli fantastico
la cosa non apre la televisione metti in
italia 1 italia 1 italia 1 si mette una
segre che cazzo la chiave perfetto per
ragazzi posso aprire la porta 3 adesso
ancora non ho capito cosa mi servono
però non mi piace il fatto che non stia
succedendo niente paga rega ragazzi
cos'è sta roba ci sono delle delle
impronte stanco che cazzo è stato mamma
c'hai delle mutande nuove grazie a mi
sono anche perso fantastico ragazzi
neanche andare dalla parte giusta non mi
piacciono manco per il cazzo comunque
andiamo andiamo avanti che è meglio
ancora non ho capito sei veramente figo
so chi tu sia ma al tuo bambino è
contentissimo
e una no no no basta straniate io
veramente mi danno fastidio ragazzi che
bug nuovo video attraverso i muri
fantasti devo andare credo che io debba
andare dove lampeggia è la stanza utile
soprattutto vedo che c'è un tante porte
ei nomi mi fa senso fifa senso se forma
fantastico si è fermato per grazia di
dio ok torniamo indietro grazie mille
ragazzi mimì mi fanno a me fanno senza
senso un casino ste cose che si chiudono
[ __ ] si può andare in un posto più
carino non lo so perché non mi piace c'è
di veramente ok come opposti uno più
bello dell'altro ragazzi di tornare ecco
ragazzi paranormal cono
vabbè c'era ma ci sono ogni tanto stiro
mori bruttissimi che non capisco da dove
arrivano a assolta amico mio nome di
quel coso è un coltello io ma vicino
adesso lo prendi proprio lo prendi ente
non lo farà gazich è un coltello grosso
così e non gliene frega proprio un cazzo
è la stanza che lampeggiava prima
fantastico si può andare avanti senza
che nessuno mi stupri non lo so e io
chiedo si può sapere che cazzo di dire
basta saperlo però basta sta merda
fatemi vedere perché sta porta aperta
letto del cazzo sorpassare lo stesso 9
non può piegare la schiena perché ha mal
di schiena quindi devo fare il giro
probabilmente ok mi ricordo troppo
outlast a parte tipo quella delle celle
cos'è non solo però era tornasse basta
basta mi sono rotto leggermente le palle
ok sono fatto due volte il due volte ho
rischiato di morire grazie di cuore una
mano di vernice ce l'ha da lei a mio zio
che con c'e cosa triste non dovete del
verde in un idea
preghiamo abbiamo il culetto è un sì ok
ce l'abbiamo ciao ragazzi un altro
coltello ovviamente non prendiamo il
coltello ma prendiamo il caso dietro
perché il coltello non serve ok perfetto
messo mezz'ora solo a prenderli quando
ci sono passato ok allora gravi
comincerò 4 ace 5
[Musica]
basta tentare di distrarsi dall'horror
cioè non è che possono mettere miste
cose ogni tre secondi
io ve lo dico si può finire sto gioco
per favore mi sto andando in ansia
veramente stupendo cioè non era così
prima sono cose per la madonna
ok già fatta a porta e l'ultima è
l'ultima perché non è non ne voglio più
sapere già visto gioco 2 sta andando ma
non incerto al centro della terra
ragazzi una culla una culla sì sapevo lo
sapevamo cene fuori dalle palle bell stì
quadri ragazzi lo voglio tutte istanze
uguali meraviglioso la cosa bella cosa
cioè no no no no fermi un attimo cos'è
sta cosa ok adesso la vedo ragazzi però
questa cosa me la dovete spiegare
legauno un povero cristiano come fa a
fare i bisogni deve attaccarsi tipo non
voglio neanche sa per la cosa non mi sta
piacendo sto sentendo rumori brutti
madre [ __ ] ma forte cos'è il corpo
tizio bobby no va bene l'altro giorno ho
trovato la testa quando il corpo e che
hanno smembrato zio bop i ragazzi tanto
era già morto si può salire per favore
che un po meglio
ok ecco bra perfetto questo intendevo
s'è chiusa una bella non mi piace sta
cosa però perché pensavo fosse finito ma
non è finito un cazzo dovrà aggiungere
l'uscito ragazzi ma questo mezzo
labirinto come faccio il quadro di
panico ricarica [ __ ] mi sono già
perso ok
sì sì che culo non so neanche come ho
fatto a trovarla ma va bene così che
dopo che è dio
no no no no no no no no no non c'è
veloce veloce veloce non c'è un'uscita
madrid la pasta che ok ci siamo fermati
ma bastano già presa a 5 maledizioni che
si può fare luce presa oggi non ha fatto
un cazzo è ancora capito mio dio questo
caso io l'ho presa mente mi chiami sono
cagato addosso rega mi sono salvato per
un 1000 ho avuto un tempo di reazione
pazzesco non sa come faccio io volo
ragazzi io volvo e non lo sapete ma io
sto a volare è impossibile comunque ho
trovato per l'ennesima volta sta cazzo
di chiave la possiamo finire ci avrei
scommesso che è stato il caduto stavolta
allora ma adesso la finiamo è la fine
cos'è
thanks for play grazie a dio sono fatto
ragazzi è stato è stato ri corri per che
cosa
ma cosa è successo mi hanno preso per il
culo hanno detto che era finito invece
nonna riqua ragazzi troppo più dio e la
madonna che postazione da gaming devo
tipo a sono entrato nel computer ragazzi
fantastico sì ma se mandando da sauro
non lo so cos'è sta roba
io continua a correre ma che non si
chiudano le pareti che mi incazzo che
non mi posso muovere carica non mi fanno
pregare brega regala ragazzi il corso si
muove ragazzi ferma ferma [ __ ]
[ __ ] da niente caramelle niente che
mln diritto meglio farsi
cosa sta succedendo don't look back
soldi non c'è niente persone pensavo ci
fosse la pizza invece no e finisse così
i ragazzi è stato brutti basta non ne
posso più fatemi togliere sta roba giuro
che è stato tragico se non si notasse
dai capelli una bella esperienza
la voglio rifare questa cosa è molto a
[ __ ] quindi ragazzi servito è
piaciuto come lasciato un commento mi
piace segue la tipa era sexy
fatelo anche la passione di facebook e
come ogni video tratta la descrizione
sono stati scritti non ci rivediamo un
prossimo video e le ragazze